once upon a time in a galaxy far far
away a young actor named mark hamill
became the very first luke skywalker but
since that star wars debut back in 1977
many others have taken a stab at the
role let's check them all out
considering how much south park loves
referencing star wars it's no surprise
that matt stone voices luke in season
11's imagination land a three-part story
arc that won the 2008 emmy for
outstanding animated program for one
hour or more
look the evil of imagination land is
coming out in imagination land luke
skywalker is a member of the council of
nine whose other members include aslan
gandolf glinda morpheus popeye wonder
woman
jesus and zeus luke joins forces with
butters in his fight against evil
imaginary characters and stone as the
heroic jedi gives a typical south park
performance bringing skywalker to life
in a way only he can
in 2021 stone and his partner trey
parker signed a 900 million dollar deal
to continue making south park for at
least six more seasons which means
there's potential for stone to reprise
the role of luke skywalker down the line
we can only hope
best known for creating the sitcom greg
the bunny dan milano operates the greg
puppet who lives with seth green's
character hi mr bender my name is greg
oh my god professor ape milano's most
notable luke skywalker performance was
in the 2007 special robot chicken star
wars he shared his duties with bob
burgin milano was later nominated for a
pair of emmy awards for co-writing robot
chicken star wars episode 2 and robot
chicken star wars 3. he voiced a few
characters in the sequels too he
returned as luke in three episodes of
mad in 2011 and 2012. milano was also a
writer and voice actor on the show star
wars detours playing the role of darth
maul among others
aiden barton is notable for portraying
the youngest version of luke on our list
and when we say young we mean
just born being a newborn himself barton
played both luke and leia as newborns in
revenge of the sith but wait a minute
how did a baby land such plum roles
because his dad roger barton was the
editor on revenge of the sith as aiden
told looper in his first ever interview
they wanted to do close-ups but they
really couldn't using a doll
right so they they brought me in my mom
came in and they just put me up there
and used me for however long they chose
to and while barton may not be credited
as an actor in the film he is included
in the special thanks section
the second season of the mandalorian
surprised fans by having luke skywalker
pop up at a pivotal moment but since the
series is set just after the original
trilogy ends mark hamill was a bit too
old for the role so british actor max
lloyd jones's face was digitally altered
to look the part
[Music]
may the force be with you
lloyd jones made his debut in 2005 in
the sandlot 2 going on to appear in
shows like supernatural and switched at
birth he was also in the film war for
the planet of the apes similar to the
mandalorian he was made to look like
someone else in this case the chimpanzee
named blue eyes
the actor later appeared in another star
wars show playing an x-wing pilot
lieutenant reed in the book of boba fett
on disney plus
if you've ever played star wars
battlefront the voice of american actor
anthony hansen is probably familiar to
you best known for providing voice work
for video games he voiced luke skywalker
in the 2015 game which brought back the
famous jedi and many others as playable
characters however as the game was
multiplayer only most characters had
very few lines
most of hansen's other credits are from
video games and he has plenty of big
ones on his resume god of war halo 5
guardians batman arkham knight lego
jurassic world and simcity he also
worked on the first season of the hit
anime series jojo's bizarre adventure
back in 2012 and he had a live action
role in the film bankroll the same year
playing the character benny big time and
just this year hanson's voice was heard
on the science fantasy game elix ii
the 2017 sequel to star wars battlefront
has matthew mercer taking on the role of
luke skywalker this time around the game
featured a single player campaign
meaning that many characters had
expanded parts luke skywalker is a
playable character in this game although
only for a brief time come on
need to work together if we're going to
get out of here mercer later provided a
number of character voices for respawn
entertainment's 2019 game star wars jedi
fall in order elsewhere mercer is known
for his work in anime dubs he has voiced
characters in some of the greatest anime
series of all time like demon slayer
himetsu no yaiba attack on titan and
jojo's bizarre adventure as a prolific
video game voiceover artist he's had
high profile roles in titanfall 2 mortal
kombat 9 and fallout 4 but he's probably
best known as the dungeon master in the
wildly popular dungeons and dragon
series critical role hello everybody and
welcome to the ninth episode of critical
role where a bunch of us nerdy ass voice
actors sit around and play dungeons and
dragons
an animated show based on the first
critical role campaign debuted to rave
reviews on amazon prime in 2022 the
legend of vox machina has a 100 rating
on rotten tomatoes
veteran voice actor christopher cory
smith made his first visit to the galaxy
far far away back in 2006 voicing
several characters for the video game
star wars empire at war he played an
imperial soldier a thai fighter pilot an
x-wing pilot and even a rebel commander
almost a decade later smith voiced luke
himself in the hour-long special phineas
and ferb star wars phineas flynn and
ferb fletcher are farmers on tatooine
who just happen to live near luke
skywalker and the plot involves perry
the platypus infiltrating the galactic
empire and stealing the data on the
death star despite taking on such
memorable roles as the joker in lego
batman the movie dc superheroes unite
smith's favorite seems to be luke during
a reddit ama smith was asked about his
favorite scene hard to say but if i had
to pick one it would be as luke
skywalker in phineas and ferb star wars
getting to say but i was just about to
go into toshi station to pick up some
power converters
canadian filipino voice actor eric
bowser made history when he became the
first non-white actor to be cast as bugs
bunny the iconic looney tunes rabbit i'm
the new voice of bugs bunny and in 2019
when warner brothers rebooted the
classic animated show bowser landed the
role of daffy duck bowser has also
played luke skywalker over a dozen times
starring as the jedi in a variety of
lego star wars projects these include
lego star wars the yoda chronicles lego
star wars droid tales and lego star wars
the freemaker adventures bowser even
voiced his version of skywalker for a
covet 19 public service announcement
back in 2020 but luke skywalker isn't
the only star wars character bows has
done he's also taken the role of gorick
wiles in the animated disney channel
series star wars resistance bowser has
also tackled a number of smaller
supporting parts in the lego star wars
universe and sharpiered marvel fans may
recognize him as the voice of
thunderbolt ross on iron man armored
adventures
veteran voice actor lloyd floyd has
played luke skywalker on several
occasions he first took on the part in
2006's star wars empire at war just one
of the many star wars video games he can
be heard in floyd reprised the role of
luke skywalker in zen pinball star wars
the force unleashed ultimate sith
edition and disney infinity 3.0 he also
worked on the game star wars the old
republic floyd as luke can also be heard
in the short film lego star wars the
empire strikes out
sorry lady outside of star wars floyd is
best known for his work on the grand
theft auto franchise you might recognize
him as dj hans oberlander along with a
wide array of characters across this
legendary rockstar franchise in a 2020
interview floyd said he's done more rock
star video games than any actor as more
characters and he's also the voice of
the joker and dc super friends making
him one of the few joker jedi out there
hello
gorgeous
bob bergen has become kind of a go-to
luke for whenever mark hamill is
unavailable voicing the character more
than a dozen times mainly in star wars
video games after debuting as skywalker
in the pc game star wars shadows of the
empire bergen went on to play the
character in star wars masters of
terrace khasi star wars rebellion star
wars rogue squadron star wars galactic
battlegrounds and star wars battlefront
2. knockout you win i'm ready he was
also involved in the robot chicken
crossover episodes playing luke
skywalker alongside dan milano
bergen has been doing luke skywalker for
so long now that he's got the character
completely figured out as he told ideo
rocket there are two versions of luke
pre-jedi and post-jedi very different
personalities it's almost like science
fiction puberty so i really worked on
and studied the character traits bergen
has had other roles in the star wars
universe
most notably as lama sue in the tv shows
star wars the clone wars and star wars
the bad batch as you know there is no
one way to make a clone
sometimes our efforts are
less than successful
joshua fardin has performed the voice of
luke skywalker twice almost two decades
apart his first time playing the
character was in the return of the jedi
radio drama on national public radio
pardon voiced skywalker in all six parts
of the series replacing mark hamill who
had voiced the character in previous
episodes the series was broadcast in
1996 some 13 years after the radio
adaptation of the empire strikes back at
the airwaves the lengthy delay was
reportedly due to public broadcasting
budget cuts but it ended up working in
favor of the producers they were able to
include all the revelations made in
other star wars media during that time
making this version of return of the
jedi arguably more compelling than the
movie pardon would later reprise the
role of luke skywalker for 2015's a new
hope read along storybook and cd and its
two sequels released the same year the
fan site coffee with kenobi gave it a
rave review saying this version boasts a
stellar voice cast much of the cast of
the radio drama is here and the quality
of voice shines through fardin has also
popped up as an actor appearing on shows
like frasier the west wing and chicago
fire he's also appeared on screen in
films such as conspiracy theory with
julia roberts mel gibson and patrick
stewart and volcano with tommy lee
jones see andrew nelson is the first
actor to play both darth vader and luke
skywalker in official star wars projects
he voiced the latter in the run and gun
super nintendo game super star wars the
empire strikes back and would again play
luke during a cutscene in the game's
star wars x-wing but nelson is far
better known for playing luke's father
nelson provided the iconic voice of
darth vader in the game's star wars dark
forces and star wars rebel assault ii
the hidden empire and even appeared on
screen as the villain in the special
edition of the empire strikes back in
fact he's logged more hours than any
other actor in the vader suit before he
started acting nelson worked at
lucasarts and was a developer on a
variety of star wars games he later
joined industrial light and magic and
was part of the visual effects teams
that brought the phantom menace and
attack of the clones to the big screen
graham hamilton is another actor who has
played luke skywalker in body only he
appeared as the jedi in the book of boba
fett but his face was digitally altered
to appear more like a young mark hamill
hamilton provided the physical movements
of the character in the sixth episode of
the series in an instagram post he
described what working with mark hamill
was like describing how bringing luke
back to life was such a magical and
fulfilling creative experience gratitude
to dave filoni and john favreau for
bringing me into the family and to all
the geniuses who remind us of the power
of myth and the deep responsibility of
artists who bring these archetypes to
life it's hard to express what this all
meant for me video game fans will also
know his voice from the last of us part
2 mafia 3 and dishonored 2 among others
and in 2019 hamilton popped up in the
tony collette lead netflix miniseries
unbelievable hamilton has also appeared
in the role of kalon primary in seth
macfarlane's hulu sci-fi comedy series
the orville i am k-lon primary welcome
to our world
you probably won't recognize lucas leon
he's a stunt performer and body double
by trade he has however played luke
skywalker appearing as the character's
young double in the rise of skywalker he
appears in a flashback sequence though
his face was of course digitally altered
to resemble that of mark hamill liang
also appeared in the rise of skywalker
as one of the knights of ren who was
killed by ben sola but the rise of
skywalker is not liang's only appearance
in a star wars film he was also part of
the stunt team for solo a star wars
story rogue one a star wars story and
the last jedi outside of the star wars
franchise he's done stunts for black
mirror and doctor strange
in terms of acting roles liang is best
known for his appearance in 24 live
another day
fans were elated when the announcement
was made that ewan mcgregor would be
returning as obi-wan kenobi in the
disney plus series of the same name and
as if that wasn't exciting enough hayden
christensen agreed to reprise the role
of anakin skywalker as well obi-wan
kenobi the series was envisioned as a
bridge between the prequel trilogy and
the original trilogy with obi-wan
watching over luke skywalker and
protecting him from a distance and with
luke being much younger here a child
actor was needed grant feely landed the
part and mark hamill was quick to offer
congratulations and support via twitter
writing grant feely looks like a perfect
luke skywalker and i am wishing him all
the very best now the young newcomer
hasn't changed that much since he filmed
his scenes as luke skywalker his first
role of real substance an appearance in
a music video aside feely only had one
acting credit prior to obi-wan kenobi in
an episode of the shutter series creep
show appearing as timmy in the timeout
segment
since his debut in the 1977 film star
wars luke skywalker has become one of
the most recognizable characters in
movie history
you can waste time with your friends
when your chores are done now come on
get to it
all right come on along with princess
leia and han solo luke skywalker is one
of the three major characters in the
original trilogy appearing in everything
from holiday specials to animated tv
shows video games comics and commercials
in star wars and you hope his first
on-screen appearance he's just a
teenager but he eventually transforms
into a skilled jedi with a mastery of
the mystical power known as the force
remember
the force will be with you always his
battles against darth vader and the evil
emperor palpatine are legendary
cinematic moments as are his
relationships with iconic characters
such as yoda r2d2 c-3po and obi-wan
kenobi but you may be surprised to learn
that mark hamill tried out for the role
of luke skywalker only after his friend
and roommate robert englund encouraged
him to do so england who you might
recognize from his role as the
terrifying freddy krueger in the
nightmare on elm street horror movie
series had been sitting in on some star
wars auditions when it occurred to him
that hamill would be a perfect fit for
luke and the rest as they say is history
on the inside of you nme podcast england
tells the story as only he can so my my
once upon a time in hollywood story is
that freddy krueger
told luke skywalker to call his agent
and he got the part and england was
right it's pretty much unimaginable
picturing anyone else but hamel in the
role of luke skywalker after playing the
part in the original star wars trilogy
he later reprised the role in the sequel
trilogy bringing the character full
circle but his death scene in star wars
the last jedi was hugely controversial
even hamel himself expressed surprise
over how it all went down telling den of
geek they totally hornswoggled me
amazing
every word of what you just said was
wrong
but he now seems to have made peace with
the project going on to say in that same
interview listen i never expected to
come back we had a beginning a middle
and an end that's what i said why mess
with it it's not something that worries
me because it's all about the new
generation as it should be in addition
to the classic films hamill also voiced
luke in the notable star wars radio
drama which aired on national public
radio way back in 1981 emmel went on to
collect many credits for his voice
acting career including his own beloved
take on the joker voicing him for
animated tv shows and video games alike
hamill also went on to do guest spots on
tv shows as varied as saturday night
live and the big bang theory but in the
end of course nothing can change the
fact that hamel is
was and forever will be the original
luke skywalker there's nothing for me
here now
i want to learn the ways of the force
and become a jedi like my father
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the star wars universe are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]